i mean i'm an engaged man yeah it's two
of us
a beautiful day really
yeah i know everyone's disappointed we
didn't engage each other but
i think we're probably gonna lose about
half the listeners now they're holding
out all those fan fictions they're just
hoping maybe one day yeah one of these
will come didn't happen yeah so now
everyone's gonna well
that about does it for this podcast yeah
we hung in there long enough time to hit
the old dusty trail hmm seems like all
those
homoerotic jokes were just jokes
unless
[Music]
[Laughter]
just just jogging around yeah one last
man that's so crazy you share
an engagement anniversary with no don't
say it don't don't [ __ ] say it well
derk in india wait what well dirk
proposed to india today or yesterday
yeah
really yeah
i thought you're gonna say something
about the well yeah and jake paul
knocking out tyra woodley
but here's the thing dude this is i was
just talking about this with kyle
this is a big huge win for me yeah i
didn't know what was going on no i swear
to god my friend or kelsey's brother
actually would show me a clip and i was
like of the knockout and i was like
what do you mean
it happened yeah i had no idea
didn't even know awesome i have some
thoughts about that we can talk about
that in a second okay but happy
engagement jake paul knocked out tyron
woodley at little dirk india day
that's fine my mine is happy elena
engagement jimin birthday
was it yeah ah it's jimin's birthday wow
happy birthday gemma by the way that's
how much i love bts wait has it been a
year since you proposed yeah
over a year yeah when did you do it what
was the day what the [ __ ] was what did
alina call you is this a trick no no no
i just was wondering october 10. okay
okay
you know what in case i ever forget
when's jimin's birthday
i would never forget jimin's birthday
ever
october 10th
idiot oh what is it october 13th what is
it
wait so did you get your proposal date
wrong get that out edit that out edit
that which date did you [ __ ] up his
birthday or the your proposal date my
proposal oh
yeah so yeah i'm uh
i'm an engaged man it feels good
feels good it was a wonderful day funny
story though so i'll tell you how it
went down my parents flew in i had her
parents her best friend flew in
um i had another best friend of one of
her best friends drive up from san diego
a couple of our other friends drove up
so there was like 15 people and her
cousins were in town too that's why i
was waiting i've had the ring for a
couple months and i was just waiting for
her cousins to be in town got it so that
we could all do it or be together and i
so i had everyone meet at this place in
malibu
and uh she like made up some lie during
brunch but why i had to go there and she
was like i don't understand like so
weird and i was like just come meet me
we'll spend the day out there it'll be
super fun and i thought i thought of
everything
in this scenario the one thing i didn't
anticipate at all was that she did not
want to go to malibu
i was like she's going to want to go
it's like the best place ever yeah and
i'm in the car and she calls me she's
like i don't understand like why do we
have to go to malibu it's an hour away
this is so annoying and i was like
that's a good point honestly but it's
gonna be fun just trust me
and so i get there early i'm freaking
the [ __ ] out were you nervous were you
[ __ ] your pants
yeah like i pissed and [ __ ] and threw up
in my pants dude i was farting and
crapping and yeah i like opened my pants
and [ __ ] puking into your nose saturdays
are back saturdays we can't do that
anymore
but yeah anyways i was microwaving my
own vomit i was so nervous and eating it
well dude
the crazy part was is when i got down on
one knee all the puking [ __ ] squeezing
out of my
joggers around my ankles going around my
shoes
and around my stomach yeah
in my shoes
you know saturdays are back enough
enough
i was definitely yeah it was it's
definitely pretty nerve-wracking yeah i
was like i don't know just it was
clearly something was going on at
breakfast like i was like
drumming on the table
and like clicking my teeth and wasn't
eating a single thing and i was like i
had too much coffee because i was like i
can tell you're being [ __ ] weird
i said i was like oh i gotta go i gotta
go and i just left
and so she's like she's like i don't
know why the [ __ ] we're going to malibu
and her cousins are like no it'll be fun
because they were in on it yeah like
it'll be great it'll be super fun let's
go
and so
she got there i was on the beach so i
had like a little beach proposal nick
set up on the beach like nice little
umbrella and some flowers and stuff like
that
and so she went straight into the house
and she didn't see anything and then she
walked in the living room and everyone
was in the living room and she's like
what the [ __ ] why is everyone here and
uh they sat her down and i made this
like long video about her relationship
and takes her through time
and
at the end it says
can you meet cody on the beach she's got
a question to ask you got it
so she walks down to the beach and uh
like the the people that did the beach
uh proposal set up or whatever
they emailed me earlier in the week and
they're like where on the beach do you
want it so i like screenshotted google
maps and i was like just put it right
here right they put it like 50 feet from
the gate right it was like way further
than i thought that i intended right so
the lock the walk that she had to take
was really like long and a little bit
like
i was like over here
and she's like okay like walking like
crying
and i'm just bawling my eyes out and
like the walk was just so awkwardly long
yeah but the funniest part was that
and then i proposed and like i was
crying so hard i could barely ask the
[ __ ] question wow it was so i was
like most emotional i've ever been wow
everything she said yes
luckily i was going to say the awkward
part is when she said no yeah exactly
she's got a long walk through the sand
and she's like she said [ __ ] it oh yeah
[ __ ] it yeah she said [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
why not
[ __ ] it the best part though
so she said yes we hug we kiss whatever
the funniest part was
before she even got there i was going to
check out like i had this whole plan
i've been planning this for weeks
everything there was so many moving
pieces like everything had to go and
that's like part of the reason i was so
nervous because there was so much [ __ ]
that had to go right yeah
and it's just funny the [ __ ] that
happens that you just don't anticipate
at all always this is what happened
i go she she's not even there yet i go
to like talk to the girl setting up the
beach thing
and as i'm walking i'm like what's that
smell
and i look down and there's a gigantic
dead seal
on the beach between the gate and where
i'm gonna propose
it's like a walrus it has like a tusk
coming out of it it's just rotting
there's like birds picking at it i was
like
could anything possibly be worse than
this this beautiful moment there's this
gigantic rotting carcass on the beach
well what's really funny is um uh you
cut some guy off in traffic and he knew
you were proposing he's like yeah i got
something for your ass and he pulled up
and he actually dragged it out of his
trunk it fell out of the flat bed of his
truck he just like went
and he
just yeah two-handed dragged it across
the beach like it's a [ __ ] show you
dude
left it
i'm like looking at this i'm like are
you [ __ ] serious my dad's like she
won't even notice it i didn't notice it
it looks like a log
and i was like perfect
so so like the gate like if if she if
i'm her right and she's looking at me
it's just a straight shot to me right
from the gate right behind me just to me
like this yeah the dead seal was
probably he was probably 10 feet to the
left right so it's like if she just
takes a straight shot she's looking at
me the whole time
we'll be fine
i'm standing there like this with the
ring watching and she comes through the
gate for some reason
takes a right
and then comes towards me literally
walks within like half a foot of this
giant rotting carcass
and you're like and you're like like a
dog
look what i'm doing
luckily she doesn't notice it and then
i'm like i'm not going to tell her
because yeah i'm not going to say like
you know ruin this perfect day remember
that carcass you walk by on the way to
the happiest moment ever
um and then i wasn't gonna tell her on
the way back i looked behind and she's
taking a selfie with the doctor it's
like there's another guy we're good nice
nice
anyways it was just like so just like
blessed that the [ __ ] sun was out the
day was perfect yeah yeah just a really
happy day you know nice i mean we had a
big group dinner with her family and my
family and everybody there
seal carcass for dinner we did we took
coming we don't waste
so we took it and
chopped it up and ate it
blubber
really good y'all were just eating
vaseline for dinner yeah
just microwaving pieces of [ __ ]
walrus
it just turns into jello that's all fat
yeah
what i love
is that
how la is that this is dead walrus and
how many people just walked around it i
know
i know
so
that is the most la thing that a whole
proposal could occur next to a dead
carcass
a [ __ ] animal just
we can't [ __ ] get away from dead
animals no we can't
yeah so i actually i ran it over with my
coffee
i was going to say you know put it on
the beach
you know put it on the beach if someone
hit it with a jet ski
it popped up out of the water for air
someone just
just scented
50 feet
i'm kidding that's how funny that's not
funny at all
there's nothing funny about hitting a
walrus on a jet ski the sound it made
when it got hit by the jet ski even
[ __ ] dolphin olympics
it's definitely not funny the sound it
would have made either yeah
it definitely was not like stepping on a
clown horn it was not like that at all
do it again
it's kicking a clown
it definitely was not funny god not
funny that's not funny at all no it's
not funny at all
eating it
no no cutting it open and eating it
mm-hmm
it's not funny thinking about it going
through the air one side's heavier than
the other so it's just doing like a
weird like
you know
tumble forward
and then when it hit the sand that was
not funny either not funny
[Laughter]
you